my name is Tina toshka I come from
Seattle which some people have described
in the past as the Amsterdam of the
United States kind of I guess so I I
want to first of all thank everyone from
being here and investing time in coming
here and listening to us and having
conversations with us because I heard
earlier today that people asked them
have no time so it's especially
important that for us to recognize the
investments that you guys have made to
come here and then spend time with us so
real quick before we get started let's
take a selfie especially with people
here in the front on three I want you to
raise your hands to smile to clap
whatever you want just make it
interesting okay and I'll put her on
Twitter lately so do it one two three
[Applause]
that's good that's good thank you so I'm
here to talk about analytics and then
the the various spectrums of analytics
that that are possible today with the
advancements in technology by Google and
by others but let's start with a quick
little story you probably have seen
these low low cars driving around with a
360 camera on top of them that's a
Google Maps on top of them for the past
ten years or so Google has been mapping
the entire world or as much as possible
and externalizing that information
through Google Maps the Google Earth you
were able to take a little yellow stick
figure and put it anywhere in the world
and walk through the neighborhoods right
that do that with neighborhoods that I
grew up and then I haven't been there in
a while
but the interesting thing is this is of
course a massive data collection and an
optimization problem and it really
speaks to you know how heavily invested
in data Google is itself but the
interesting thing here is up until
recently up until the last four or five
years this was just imagery right you
couldn't and maybe coordinates and
things like that you couldn't really
gain as much insight as possible from
this but
with advancements in AI and with
advancements in in commoditization of
computer hardware and improvements in
computing power especially in AI machine
learning we're able to derive further
information from this imagery so for
example we can understand that the
business has turnover right there's a
new business in place there so we can go
into Google Maps and update the place of
business or maybe you know the sign was
in there before maybe it was a two-way
street and now you can't go this way so
it's very important for us to tell you
that you can't go down this road so all
of this of course is done automatically
through our through our AI learning
capabilities so this is this right here
is probably the worst kept secret in
Silicon Valley Google is very serious
about analytics it says so in our model
says googles mission is to organize all
the data that's possible in the world
and present it for better good for
everyone right so Google has built a
number of technologies that it uses
internally right to organize this
information and the premise of Google
cloud platform is to be able to
externalize these technologies the
lessons learned and the power of compute
for your benefits so you can run
alongside Google leveraging the same
Google investments and technology and
innovation for yourselves as well which
hopefully accelerates your pace of
innovation accelerates your either
iteration allows you to deliver faster
better more interesting features allow
your customers and the fact that Google
has been a data-driven company for such
a long time and has built these services
that allow you to to do some really
powerful things things with that and
analytics has made it fairly easy for us
to become a machine learning company as
well
this chart probably means updating but
essentially for the past five or so
years virtually every single product and
service that Google has has become in
some ways and often in many ways AI
driven right so if if you use Google
photos for example right you can very
clearly understand
the type of inference that occurs on
your content automatically right it
allows you to create stories based on
just the imagery that's happened and the
ability to pull out metadata about that
imagery but of course you can have too
much of a good thing right going back to
that example where Google has generated
a whole lot of photos of a whole lot of
streets around the world and if you need
to go back in time and process all that
information that is a very serious
computing power so you can have too much
of a good thing right you can have too
much of a requirement for AI especially
for inference right which is which is
asking the model what the model thinks
is happening right so in the last few
years Google has been faced with a
problem a serious problem right we have
too much demand for inference and the
you know we were faced with having to
expand into dozens of dozens of new data
centers and if you've ever seen a
picture of a data center that Google
operates these are huge things they're
bigger than this venue here so two
serious investment takes time it's it's
complex so we implemented tensor
processing units GPUs and now we're on
version 2.0 GPUs are specially optimized
for matrix algebra that allows you to
especially essentially infer a result of
a model essentially GPUs allow us to
save a whole lot of energy right and so
these are live inside of Google for the
past several years their intricate
they're delicate
and they're really important to our
infrastructure so on to a little bit
more practical terms what I talk to data
scientist AI experts machine learning
experts they tend to say you know
excited you know in day-to-day
activities what they do some folks tell
me well I have to operate an HBase
cluster because that's where our data is
kept or I have to take data from you
know Hadoop run a hive query create a
cohort and feed that into a model that's
lived somewhere else or have to run a
bunch of sequel queries before I can
even feed anything into my model to
the my sample and so forth so ultimately
focused on with a 90 percent of really
true AI machine learning workloads
involve pure data science or maybe even
data engineering right so when you're
faced with complex problems like that
it's really important to try to minimize
complexity right where wherever it's not
necessary so this is really something to
the interesting to keep in mind right
you can get lost in the noise very
easily but then according to Gardiner a
whole lot of projects to try to create
you know Big Data infrastructure data
leaks end up failing I'm not sure how
accurate that's saved in this but it
it's quite possibly true right so it's
very hard to do big data in 2017 right
Hadoop's complex HDFS complex you need
to have a lot of expertise so how do you
compute this how do you if you want to
be an AI driven organization and a
practice if reaiize data science but 90%
of data science projects fail that's
kind of a daunting proposition right so
I like to use this django analogy
there's probably familiar with Django
right this especially a basic game where
you pile on wooden bricks on top of each
other and you pull out a bit from here
and you put it on top so what you want
to think about that infrastructure as
entirely interdependent bricks on top
depend on bricks on the bottom and you
want to have a very clean Jenga tower so
it doesn't topple so at the bottom you
can think about this as based on
architecture right what I mean by that
is you want to have a good networking
you want to have you want to choose a
good public cloud provider or two you
might want to have a really good data
center right you want to get that right
and on top of that you want to have
really good compute right virtual
machines servers containers and good
storage object storage for example
and that aids you in developing your
good applications and databases to power
these applications right so in order to
have good applications you probably need
to have those two right only then you
can start thinking about a prop or data
warehouse you can certainly do a data
warehouse without getting all that right
but it's you know it really helps you to
have the foundational blocks tacked up
before data warehouse are you probably
gonna say - you know that's data
warehouse is kind of an old term don't
use there anymore we have a data like
sure but sometimes data leaks kind of
get stale and they turn into data swamps
but but you drain the swamp and you have
everything right and now your data leak
is so big you can call it a data ocean
now fantastic well it's just you know
let's just summarize all that and just
use one umbrella data large body of
water right I claim that you can ask me
to use it but that's mine that a large
body of water and once you have that a
large body of water setup then you can
start thinking about AI machine learning
there are some exceptions you guys saw
earlier today and I can talk about them
some more but that's really you know the
lesson here and of course it's a Jenga
tower analogy so if you build a bad
Jenga tower it's probably going to
topple hence the ninety percent of all
data Lake projects fail that's really
the lesson here okay
so now that I've scared you sufficiently
let's talk about what a modern data
analytics stack looks like there's
probably a whole lot of attributes you
can identify that you can you can say
this is what has to be enough modern
data analytics stack so I have four that
I want to talk to you about the first
one is
separation of storage and compute and
it's it is a little bit of a loaded term
so let me quantify exactly what's
happening here
separation of storage compute is really
a solved problem it buys you so many
options when you're designing your
system if you don't have this and you
are operating a decently sized scale you
should you should look into this
yesterday right it's just the pros and
cons of having this attribute or just
tremendous in your favor right so this
is solve problem get it done here's what
I mean about pure separation storage
compute it's exactly that right there's
a fine line between processing and
compute and storage and that fine line
is actually represents very powerful
networking networking that can talk that
allows every node within a data center
to talk to every other node within the
same data center at 10 gig all at the
same time right so Google's data centers
last reported have over a petabyte of by
sectional bandwidth per second per data
center so that's kind of a requirement
you have to have good networking but
ultimately in practical terms you can
have your various storage layers whether
you have BigTable which is our Google's
no sequel database you can have bigquery
storage which is our data warehousing
data Lake storage where you can have
object store where you keep your cat
videos and you can have Google Cloud
dataflow for example which are is our
batch and stream processing unified
programming model and engine access all
of those regardless of whether they live
or potentially you can have bigquery
sequel which is standard run sequel
queries and all those not cat videos but
just ignore that for a sec and you can
have your own Hadoop and spark clusters
run on top of that information as well
so I'm not discounting the the
significance that the Hadoop and spark
have in today's environment it's the the
momentum behind these projects is
phenomenal right so we have Google Cloud
Data proc which is our fully managed
higher a spark Hadoop and flink service
the awesome thing about our service
specifically is that you can get the
clusters very very quickly
90 seconds hopefully
see that over there 90 seconds is 99
percentile from the moment you push the
button to the moment your cluster is
live ready to use that's very fast
especially within you know if you're
coming from your own on-premise private
data center space the typical numbers
that I hear involves six to nine months
and sometimes it'll longer so 90 seconds
is just a phenomenal change right enable
so many options there of course we have
pay per minute right so you can shut
this thing down after 20 minutes if
you'd like to you save the results into
a storage that's that's where the state
is and because we have fully ephemeral
printable the ends which you know kind
of disappear everyone's tomorrow
exchange for 80% off of list price so
you can have very quick Hadoop clusters
that you can shut down whatever you want
because you pay about a minute and you
actually don't pay a whole lot for it
so the idea is that Hadoop doesn't
completely keep a lot of state unless
it's intermediate state state lives in
storage like initial state and output
was in any of these storage pieces the
other really big point here is that data
silos are bad right you're playing the
game of telephone with data right when
you're moving data around needlessly
ultimately you end up with multiple
copies of data and the funny thing
happens right when two data scientists
try to get the same answers to the same
problem using the same data that data
lives in other places they'll come up
with different results I'm still not
sure how that happens but data silos are
bad and separation of storage and
compute allows you not to deal with that
so here's another different analogy that
I can use and of course why I apologize
- especially to the cxos this is you
know we don't think of you that poorly
from these stick figures but ultimately
the this is what your potential
organization can look like right even at
a start-up you can have this type of
delineation and you can have your
various bits of data are living inside
of bigquery right from all the way from
very very raw data that comes from
application databases and services
to data that's potentially sensitive
that you don't necessarily want to have
floating in our everywhere to real-time
dashboards you know things that tell you
the state of your business and all the
way to data that you can potentially
want to externalize from your
infrastructure to your third parties to
clients because they find using that so
they all have different roles here and
the nice thing about our separation is
towards compute just like with Google
Docs Google sheets where you can in
place share information and share
collateral with other folks within your
organization's outside you can do the
same thing with our data like data body
of water services so ITN Ops could
potentially have their the overreaching
role of this organization they want to
own every single data set they all want
to administer that that's fine and so
you know access controls they say I'm
the owner and everything right just like
in Google Docs but the data engineers
may only need to have viewer access to
to the really raw data set the really
important data sets because you don't
want to mess that up
but then they're the ones that are
creating dashboards they're the ones
that are creating these data sets and so
they have editor access to that of
course the did obvious follows write
your your executives get a real-time
dashboard in View mode and you can even
share in place without having an FTP
server in place you can share your data
with third parties right so they can run
sequel analytics in real time without
having to do a lot of work on top of
your data this was pretty awesome and I
said this already data silos are bad
it's it's a relic of old architectures
try to avoid that ourselves so the
second aspect of modern analytics I want
to talk about is this concept of
surveillance and of course you've heard
of the various terms that are various
contacts within which serverless is
mentioned
so the the most confined definition of
server list is such a cloud functions
right tiny little piece of code you
execute one out of time
but it's it's the industry has been
extending this buzzword further into
identifying some things that have a very
high level of abstraction something's
that are fully managed that essentially
allow you to use the ephemeral very very
scaleable pieces of compute and compute
and only pay for the resources that you
use so our server list analytics kind of
central piece here is bigquery I
actually I was on the bigquery team
before recently and it's an amazing
product if you haven't used it you
should definitely look into it the
quarry is our fully managed analytics
data warehouse it does have separation
storage and compute as a very very
powerful storage engine that's self
optimized the self feels it tries to
understand how you're using the storage
and burns a whole lot of CPU and RAM to
optimize the storage for your war-club
does that on your behalf so it's kind of
it's opinionated in that regard and of
course that storage component allows you
to share data with the new organization
or outside of your organization in very
elegant ways right without having to
copy that data around on the other side
the query has a compute engine right
it's basically drama and drama you can
go read the paper that's published by
Google Travel execute sequel queries in
real time very very fast
analytical workloads and the query has
an incredibly high level of abstraction
you never have to touch Hardware you
never have to define storage or compute
or and it really not a whole lot of
configuration there and that's on
purpose right because we want you to
focus on what's important to you so
let's take a look at what the quarry
looks like if you haven't seen it
so this is the bigquery UI which is one
of the many ways you can interact with
bigquery and at first it doesn't really
look all that exciting right it's kind
of looks aged a little bit right kind of
looks like Gmail from 2004 but just like
Gmail from 2004 when when you had what a
gigabyte inbox right away when you know
you were yelling at your grandma which
sent you a 30 megabyte video because
your inbox would explode and now you get
a gigabyte that's amazing and so just
like Gmail in 2004 hides a whole lot of
complexity and a whole lot of power
underneath the hood in the simple UI the
query does the exact same thing so let
me show you so this is right here bokura
petabyte is a data set right kind of
like a data base the bigquery has and
I'm click on this sales partition table
here which is a table that we made up
it's not real data we did it for the
purposes of demonstrating the power of
bigquery so there's nothing super
special about it I'm gonna look at the
schema here of this table well you see
here that's really really interesting so
it's typical you know order execution
when it happened how much but here we
have actually nested structures like we
have an array inside of the table that's
pretty awesome so you can have an array
of an array JSON like structures they're
very complicated or very simple but it
kind of allows you to have interesting
relationships with your data here so
that's a schema if I'm gonna click on
what the table looks like yet you see
here that the table size is a little bit
over a petabyte it's a decently sized
table and that looks
that was like a tree yeah trillion Rose
trillion rows in this table so the most
sensible thing to do with this table is
to try and query it live so I'm going to
I have the safe query here
so I just push the big red button to set
run query' oh no I had to catch turn on
so we're gonna not cheat we're not gonna
have cash but if you look at this query
the only thing that I'm doing here to
really cheat is that this pickup title
my table has three years worth of data
we're only doing
we're only calling a one month of
petition but otherwise it's querying a
whole lot of data and you know it's got
a join it's got a big all regular
expression it's kind of window function
everything you can possibly imagine in a
typical query right mix back Oh looks
like we finished this in you know 16 and
a half seconds so this table didn't have
anything special there's no keys there's
an index says between doing the
optimizations really outside of what the
query service itself provides in terms
of our to automation optimization all we
did was load that data into bigquery
so that's that's the demo here so let's
talk about what exactly happened so I
know I've ran a square before so I know
how much resource it takes to execute
this query in under 20 seconds so it's
about 3,000 course so you could
potentially take that data set and if
you have 3,000 core drive around you
deploy that assuming you have similar
software to the query you can you can
execute that you can run your own demo
of that if you like and so that's really
what we did right we ran to 3,000 cores
from Google for the length of the job so
let's think about this in virtual
machine terms right virtual machines
take minutes to start you can turn our
billing maybe per hour per minute maybe
and virtual machines it's hard to get
3,000 course very quickly right so what
the query allows you to do is to go from
zero to 3,000 for only 16 seconds 20
seconds and you get the equivalent of
only paying for what you consume now the
asterisk here is that bigquery charges
not per second it charges for the amount
of data
but that's a great proxy to think about
when you try to when you try to relate
this to virtual machines right but
that's all fun and dandy the really key
benefit of server lists is that you get
a whole lot of power for very short
periods of time and you don't even care
that that's happening right all you care
about is you have data you wrote our
interesting sequel query and you'll push
the red big red button and you want to
get the results right that's what you
care about like you sometimes you might
want to geek out and then think about
that but ultimately this is where you
live and that's the benefit of service
really right so that's a lot of power
very short bits of time and of course if
you want to stand up to tensorflow
and machine learning technologies our
fully managed cloud machine learning
engine service allows you to do the
exact same things on top of CPUs and
GPUs so you can rent ultimately you can
rent lots and lots of resources for
short periods of time without having to
worry to stand out those resources
manage those resources in order for you
to train your tensorflow models and once
the models complete you can take that
into your own environment good thing to
take that into google cloud platform and
deploy it or even on your mobile devices
for example and you might have seen this
already in other in other talks but the
one exception to that whole Jenga
analogy that I've used earlier is that
there's been a whole lot of research
done by Google and by other technologies
to train models on large bits of data
Google has a good amount of data right
so we've taken our investments in
technologies and we're externalized them
through simple api's rest Dave yes right
so any developer can use them implement
them inside of your your application now
you have an AI driven application and
you can certainly get that next round of
funding if you say yeah I in your name
so the third aspect I want to talk about
is real-time real-time analytics is also
solved problem there are certainly use
cases where you can have batch nightly
analytics hourly but you have a very
easy path to getting analytics on data
as it occurs
and this is a very typical you know path
that our organizations take Spotify is a
blog about this quite extensively and
other other companies of course New York
Times is an avid user of this right here
it's a very high level of abstraction
across three services that allow you to
move data from the moment there occurs
in your application to the moment that
you have precomputed analytics right you
have a dashboard do you trying to to
develop here and so the moment that you
won't have real-time access to sequel to
your analyst to data scientists whose
data all that is built right you just
have to implement it and it's it's a
very popular way of doing things today
the last thing I want to talk about is
each gem I know I have to do ETL
sometimes and I don't really find that
necessarily too enjoyable right it means
to an end there's no glory in it so ETL
should be easy right we should just get
that in as quickly as possible have it
as quick as clean as possible and focus
on value again so I'm gonna give you
quick demo what I'm talking about
so I have this data set here called
citibike data this is just a bunch of
rows I actually took the queries public
data sets and I exported them for this
demo so just a bunch of information and
I ran this I'm gonna run this by Corey
job who's gonna take this I need to
update my CLI I need to basically I'm
taking that data and hopefully the
Internet holds up and I'm going to load
it into bigquery for quick analysis
waiting it gonna air
oh no I'm kidding I made that so it
looks like the error says at position
751 there's close double quotes have
something inside of them all right well
I'm gonna go to let's go to that line
this is the line that's talking about
mm-hm
oh I see it what it is right so I have
this quality in here and inside of it is
an escape character that the court
doesn't like for some reason and of
course there is an RFC on it that says
four comma delimited values you can only
escape quotes with other quotes and the
query is very pedantic it likes RFC's so
it rejects your data so what do we do
well we have this other tool called data
prep you can leverage today and I'm
going to create a job instead of data
flow that will hopefully recognize that
information so I'm gonna go ahead and go
through the flow of importing that file
instead of data proc there it is
it's going to load that file in or at
least some part of it and then it's
going to run some statistical analysis
to understand what exactly is going on
right is going to try to understand what
the data looks like do that yep it's
gonna try to understand what the data
looks like if there are outliers if
there are errors if it's going to try to
parse through this information and so on
and so forth so it looks like it created
this thing for me here and this is
basically a ETL job right I have the
file and it's going to create a job and
this is the recipe that it's going to
execute which is very simple you can
certainly make that more complex so
we're gonna look at the data and see
exactly what happens here and how we
wait
but the idea here again is that the how
it's taking really slow I did not have
enough contact prepared to fill this
time but ultimately what is going to
happen is going to take that that bad ro
that that I throw in there and it's
going to recognize that ro and it's
gonna say hey that is actually you know
an escape character it's not conforming
to an RFC but we definitely think it's
an escape character so Wow
live downloads don't always work I guess
so
let's forget about that you're just
gonna have to take my word for it so
well the tool like data prep you have
one-click ETL right you can take ugly
data as you know if it works you can
take ugly data that doesn't conform to
any standards and you want to get on one
or write Python code or anything like
that you just want it in one place for
you to analyze right so data prep is a
fantastic tool for that under the hood
the a the flow data prep actually
creates apology beam pipelines right it
takes the crazies recipes that turn to
Apache beam pipe lines and then execute
them on top of Google Cloud dataflow so
you're familiar with that technology
this is actually a pretty cool way of
doing things so data prep is awesome so
to very quickly summarize the the
practice of data architecture data
infrastructure is moving very very
quickly but there are pillars that
emerge that become very obvious winds
very very quickly right and and these
pillars can simplify your life and this
is kind of like can I have things
simpler cheaper and faster yes right
this is because the architecture is
fundamentally change you can save money
and get more right that's the lesson
here so that's really the four things
that I've identified I'm sure you can
find many many more I'm going to close
this on saying that you know the whole
concept of serverless the idea here
again is that
we want to provide the highest level of
abstraction possible to automate all the
noise or the tinkering all the things
that are they're not really that
important to you right you don't want to
tinker abstract that away automate that
away and give you a surface that allows
you to create value so instead of doing
very low value and a whole lot of
tinkering we want to flip our equation
on its head so we want to give you the
ability to create a lot of value and
very little tinkering that's what's
travel this means sorry thank you very
much but before we finish I'm gonna have
Jeffrey and Konstantin come on stage
we're gonna have some just a quick
little fireside chat where we can take
questions from each other and from the
audience as well
Jeffrey comes from RTL and his
organization implemented some
interesting analytics workers on top of
Google and Konstantin is from a services
partner that helped Jeffrey implement
this please
[Applause]
thanks for coming guys
can you tell me more about your
organization RTL yeah RTL is not only a
TV broadcaster it's a multimedia company
so we have also a lot of digital assets
and nobody knows what the RTL group is
the largest content a blogger on YouTube
in Europe and we work a lot with the
Google products also in the sills domain
in it examine and also go on it at the
big data doing so when it comes to big
data specifically it's a big data
session what have you guys done what did
you implement we store the data in
Google storage Considine helped us with
building the we have a spark platform so
he built the platform based on data proc
and we have the query on top of that so
it's a nice distribution of products
that we have implemented and that helps
us in all various ways it's very
transparent it's easy to use the setup I
can go to my business stakeholder and
tell them exactly which query takes that
much long it cost me so much euro if you
want to have it faster no problem I can
put more machines on and you can have it
fast it that's the decision up to the
business so that makes it really
transparent really really powerful so it
sounds like your business was with the
help of google cloud platform was really
enabled to perform better analytics some
more data talk about more yeah what they
liked about it yeah bring the decision
back to the business if they want to
have it faster
you can have it yeah
so it's up there decision if you have it
within 15 minutes I don't mind we'll
make it shorter in 50 minutes goes a
little bit more but it's their decision
it's not a 90 decision it's a business
decision that's fantastic
and so I've I'm aware that you guys are
leveraging Google the query can you talk
more about this particular piece for our
infrastructure yeah Vickery helps us a
lot in our grow intelligence maturity
mm-hmm so like every company we have a
set of reports that helps you by
measuring how many customers you have
how many revenue have a blah blah blah
but then it happens that customers go
away cancel the subscription or the
revenue drops down so reports sales fear
about what's happening and then you want
answers on why people left why cancel
their description then you have to go
into the data and it tells business
people to query a large datasets finding
answers on why people laugh what was the
behavior before they left so it empowers
again business people not a group of
data scientists taking create they can
do a lot know business people you give
acts to large data sets and finding
answers on and the problems you see over
horizon your reports very powerful yeah
and I wish you know I wish Big Data
buzzword was actually called holistic
buzz holistic data because it allows you
to store very raw information about
what's going on with your applications
how your users are interacting your
application so the further down the line
you can have your analysts understand
specifically what the behaviors were
right then why they left your platform
yeah when you have those answers then
you can ask data scientists yeah and
make predictive modeling yeah but it's
the step in between that you want to
have a broader audience in your company
people in the business market is sales
people there has also access to large
data sets yeah and it's really important
to make that grow to also to AI and
chi'lan
yeah yeah which leads me to my next
question what's your take on a a
machine-learning what are your plans and
what are the opportunities within your
organization we are a total video
company so we have a lot of content
video content that's what I like about
RTL so we analyzed the content the video
because it tells me about the quality of
the content so we have a lot of content
that must help me about what is the I
want to quantify the quality of the
content yeah so I use also the video API
it's but we also installed denser flour
and clear us to have a better
understanding what's happening on screen
and that generates a lot of metadata
tags labels that helps me also my
recommendation so I can prove that
little war I need neither have a better
understanding quality of content we
haven't forgotten about you Constantine
so constancy was one of the gentlemen
that there are a whole lot of the heavy
lifting on this project can you tell us
more about what you've done
yeah when I started with the project
they already were using Hadoop and spark
but they had their own on-prem cluster
with a fixed amount of machines so that
was also a started was very expensive
because it was always home 24/7 and that
meant it was either it was not big
enough because they wanted their data
now or it was standing around costing
money doing nothing and it also meant
there was one cluster so if two people
at the same time want to do something
with the data they had to wait for each
other and yeah there were multiple data
scientists multiple data engineers and
also multiple data analysts and if one
of them is using the cluster the others
are not doing anything useful for RTL
and at the same time I also noticed that
keeping there your own Hadoop and spark
cluster up and running can be quite
labor intensive and RTL would much
rather spend that effort doing useful
business things then running after their
Hadoop spark cluster so I suggest that
we could move them over to data probe
for starters and yet and then they could
stop worrying about maintaining them and
at the same time like the example showed
if you want a 100 node cluster right now
that's fine and if that only your job
only takes 10 minutes then you throw it
away
if there's three people that want to do
something at the same time you spin up
three clusters and then you throw away
three clusters so you can just keep
working and like Dino cept also in this
slide if you separate the data from your
compute three people want to work at the
same I want to work at the same data set
that's also fine yeah because you're not
tied to get one data set that lives over
in that one cluster
how long did your project take the whole
project was several months but it also
included like mostly understanding the
data one of the nice things about using
Google Cloud was that the setting of the
infrastructure basically took me 15
minutes because I've done it before but
I just click I want a cluster I uploaded
their data to I have uploaded their data
to Google Cloud the best set and one of
their existing spur jobs that they were
already running on premise and within 15
minutes I had working infrastructure and
I can could start spending the rest of
the time actually analyzing the data and
figuring out what to do with it rather
than babysitting the infrastructure you
know so going forward what would be your
recommendation if you were going to
implement this type of infrastructure in
the future well if you already have a
spark you can just take your existing
spark jobs that usually work on HDFS and
put your data in Google storage so you
get the data separation cloud data Pro
comes with integration for Google
storage basically the same way you use
HDFS so you can just take your put your
data in Google storage take your
existing job and
stains the output from HDFS to Google
storage and just run it yeah that's a
great first step
any other comments either one one would
like to share about the project's OS
constants it's it's easy and relatively
easy to manage so you can allocate your
time more on business problems so the
maintenance is relatively easy
it's transparent and what I also like is
that each as you explain data scientists
come to the office in the morning
they spin up the cluster and here to go
then so they're not interfering with
each other no and so and maybe use all
the same the old cluster all the
applications are there so they can play
around and today they did start this I
want a cluster of
ten machines and tomorrow I'll do a
different type of algorithm and I'll
spin up a cluster of fifteen machines up
to them and I know exactly as a manager
who was using what so I can all say you
burn too much lower down or spin up
because I think yeah that's the three
helps linear data scientists and it also
helped later on the project because the
original project used spark to put their
data into an existing pre-process the
data into a normal sequel database but
that means that sometimes that when some
of the data engineers are busy I've
literally told them hear them hear them
tell one of the data analysts like can
you please not do you do your work until
2:00 in the afternoon because I'm busy
using the database and yeah I understand
from a technical perspective because
like the data engineer was just keeping
the database very busy but you don't
want that so instead of putting the data
into our normal database we put the data
and Vickery's and as you saw and
rtl has lots of data because like
Joffrey says there's a large multimedia
presence on the internet from RTL not
just the RTL label with multiple labels
and that literally generates billions of
data points and I can just put those
into bigquery I don't even have to
aggregate them anymore so before all the
data was aggregated and you could only
get the reports that the aggregation was
specifically made for and now all the
data has just in there and there are
some supreme some pre-made aggregations
to make things easier on the users but
it's basically do whatever you want and
again because it's serverless
as long as you don't request more
compute power than google has like he
don't make google crash then they can go
nuts fantastic and we challenge you to
do that so we have a few minutes to take
questions for the audience so please
raise your hand and there's no be a
microphone coming around please right
thank you what's the difference between
big canary on a spanner
fantastic question so the accordian
spanner are used extensively internally
at Google and by our clients the easiest
way to think about is the query is great
for analytics whereas you know things
like aggregating lots of information and
spanner is a fantastic tool to create an
an application or to have an operational
database right then they go hand and
hand together and actually both speak
the same standard secret language
any other questions please another
question over there your 20 seconds
query of 3000 notes
what's the money being spent that's a
great question so the that particular
query cost about $10 to run yeah so the
cordilla has two pricing models
specifically one is paper job as I did
and for folks who are at a larger scale
who has specific use cases you can you
can pay a flat monthly fee that includes
any queries good question
I am like a lot of bi departments in our
company we're a bit of a bottleneck when
it comes said day of preparation today a
prep looks cool because we get out there
how difficult would it be to
productionize the output of day that's a
good question in terms of production
eyes you want to put this into a place
where analysts can work on it
sure select an analyst might get yeah
any files they do that thing and then
we've got six thousand files that we
need to run through a nightly process
and that's a kind of production yeah
that is an intra it's exactly the use
case for NATO prep so it's an intrinsic
quality of that service actually you
have to do pretty much the exact same
thing at RTL one of the nice things
about bigquery is that next to its
native custom drivers that are really
fast it also has an existing ODBC driver
and it's and it speaks standards and CC
cool so it can talk with anything that
can talk Seco over ODBC and that is
basically anything that's cuz its calls
itself Sabet that data and LIXIL can
talk with it
so at RTL the main tool for business
intelligence is business object and I
just set up an ODBC query and we're in a
couple days
Business Objects could talk to bigquery
and no one would notice the difference
and there's also several other tools
with RTL just the own departments using
their own tools and as long as they can
talk od BC with standard and see sequel
then it just works where we're
essentially out of time but we'll take
one final question right there thank you
thanks for taking my question so
a lot of analytic projects live in an IT
landscape not just a Google landscape
can you say something about how to roll
out into production both code and
infrastructure and and how you see
integration with with existing let's say
applications and deployment pipeline so
I'm thinking how do you use this stuff
with git how do you how do you roll that
stuff yeah an RTL we had our pipelines
were in code there's two out there
called the air flow that's remote also
from apache and that's allows you to
model all your data pipelines as code so
there's jobs in there like spin up a
cluster around the spark job spin down
the cluster and take the output from
that spark job and put it into bigquery
that's all code so and that code lives
in a git repository so and there's a
Jenkins on top of that get repository so
if I commit to master Jenkins runs it
runs the tests if the tests look good it
automatically puts it to the accept
environment and if I hit the button the
same we have code goes to production
that's that the value of ecosystem that
creates orchestration and monitoring is
that that can be understated right so
Google specifically invested in
partnerships and the supporting open sis
open source technologies like air flow
right that we've extended into our
services and if there are technologies
that they're compelling that we don't
know about we want to know about them as
well yeah thank you folks
I think this is we've run out of time
but thanks for your time great thank you
you
[Applause]